starting us off this hour is Joe in New
York Hey Joe welcome to the Dave Ramsey
Show
how you doing Dave better than I deserve
man how can I help
so I have a question today so me and my
wife bought a business a few years ago
around 280 000 we bought it for and then
we're ready to get out uh four years
later and we're gonna sell it for around
600 000 or go on 580. good
yeah so um our question is uh we have
around sixty thousand dollars in debt
and we wanted to know would it be wise
for us to invest that full almost 300
000 into mutual funds with a certain
bank or should we just pay off debt
first well definitely pay off the debt
first you said you got 60 000 in debt
oh yeah it's around 60 yes okay you owe
anything on your mortgage
uh well we're renting right now we don't
have a house okay
all right
um are you planning on buying a home
we were planning on buying a home but
when we uh spoke to someone who's
um who for a friend of ours who found
out about our situation they said that
um it would be why for us to invest the
money and pay off the debt with whatever
we get in return from the mutual funds
yeah well that person's stupid
um
they explained to us that we would get
around like 20 of whatever we invested
20 percent
yeah they recommended Charles Schwab and
they told us that um the invest with
them they have really good Returns on
their funds yeah so this guy doesn't
know what he's doing whoever he is okay
stock market has averaged 11.8 percent
since it began which is half of 20 and
Schwab's got no corner on the market
they're no they're not going to get 20
anymore than anybody else is so you
invest in good mutual funds you can
expect 10 to 12 percent if you do a
really really good job of picking the
funds over a long period of time
but you're not going to expect 20 that's
that's asinine okay there's no data to
back that up whatsoever so whoever this
guy is you stay away from his financial
advice
um and I would sit down not with Schwab
but with a good uh investment broker
that uh actually builds a relationship
with you over a long period of time
click smartvestor daveramsey.com I'm not
in the business I don't care what you do
but these are the people we recommend uh
and it's the type people I personally do
business with if you're going to do
investing so I'd write a check and be
debt free I would raise my right hand
and promise to never borrow again
otherwise this won't work
um and then I would think about buying a
house for cash with this remaining money
sounds like you're gonna have four or
five hundred thousand dollars after you
pay off the debt
you're getting five something out of the
business
and so um you may have some debt there
that you're not mentioning to clean up I
don't know but
um I'm gonna start talking about paying
cash for a house and no I'm not
borrowing on my house to invest with
Charles Schwab so that's just that's
just butt dumb right there unbelievable